[Music]
you ever see those two
uh you know this kid that's blown off
blown up on tick tock right now this
like russian kid the
one that has the disease that makes him
look like a toddler yeah yeah
uh the little baby looks like quinn yeah
he does and you posted the side by side
i said oh that was pretty funny it does
look like quinn
yeah um because he's been all over mma
twitter i've just
intentionally ignored him it literally
he's just
every mma meme anytime i've been on
twitter it's
driving me nuts really yeah so i've just
is it supposed to be him and another
like it's another kid with the same
disease
okay and they're gonna fight each other
i saw
a clip of him practicing with gloves and
the gloves were as big as his body
yeah i was just i couldn't imagine how
that fight was gonna go down yeah i mean
it's like this
this if you haven't seen this skateboard
probably no chance you haven't seen it
because
he's everywhere like you said yeah
everywhere yeah
uh he's like 17 i think and he his like
this disease that he has makes him look
like he's
like three or like like a toddler
basically and it's so bizarre because
like he's got the skin and everything of
like a baby but his like mannerisms are
super mature yeah
it's bizarre uh and so now he's
he's his videos went viral because like
people are like this is
it's this kid how young is he they don't
know and now he's fighting this other
kid with the same disease
and it's like is that safe for them is
it like even
ethically okay to like watch that it's
kind of like
like baby fighting that's what i'm
saying it's like
disorganized baby combat yeah this is
not
it's probably illegal yeah you you they
don't let dogs fight
yeah exactly they don't i don't know why
they'd it'd be cool to let
two because all right
you know mentally they're not children
mentally they've been on this earth for
17 years but physically
they qualify as children yeah so yeah is
it abuse at that
point that's what i'm saying i mean i
guess like they're they're probably like
they're their own person they have their
own they can decide what to do with
their bodies
yeah yeah that's true that's true but
also should we be looking out for them
because if they're
like as soft as you know avocados
yeah you know it's our avocados pretty
soft
ripen yeah or is it the other way around
avocados yeah
you're not aware no of how of like the
form factor of an avocado no
okay do you not like avocado
uh it just it just fluffs with my throat
every time i eat it okay fair yeah
you can that's that's how weak i am you
could probably just
kill me with an avocado like i'd do all
this
physical training but really all it
would take is just three slices of
avocado in my sleep and i would die
i would the [ __ ] way to die
i could have survived an avocado toast
that's a weapon in my house how do you
even live in l.a then how are you
yeah i don't even survive i don't eat
that's how i stayed there because i
can't really find anything to eat every
time you go for brunch you just have
water
i'll just have water and air thank you
like oh that's a wonderful option as
well we're gonna split a water
yeah that's what most people get here
actually yeah if you've never been to la
that's
what la promotes is unhealthy eating
it's that's the whole menu it doesn't
matter where you go it's either avocado
toast or a splitting of water
nothing else we're gonna split of water
yeah i think me and my girlfriend just
have the ice
yeah we got an audition next week i
don't want to get too crazy
we're going to split the ice
we're going to salt and straw after this
yeah we're going to have the ice there
as well
[Laughter]
we're going to have salted ice
[ __ ] goat cheese flavored ice yeah
we're gonna have food flavored ice over
there at salt and straw
nah yeah yeah like are they still do
they still have the soft spot on their
heads what i'm saying
like is one of them i also don't know if
that's [ __ ] up to ask or not you know
i also have no idea how much of this you
can actually
question or how much i wonder how this
what is this disease actually i've never
seen it before
uh let's see can we look it up if i just
google
all right if i google bet no baby
disease
no yeah i was gonna say benjamin button
no it's not like they're aging in
reverse
it kind of is they've just never aged oh
yeah okay
fair yeah it's not really
yeah all right two dwarfs all right so
they they're not dwarfs though are they
i don't even think you can say that word
i don't even
use that you can say dwarf can you yeah
that's like a medical term i don't think
so i think that's dwarfism
is it yes i thought that's like a
medical term from like
58 no it's not look it up search that
there needs to be a separate google for
what can get you canceled yeah i know
seriously there needs to be there needs
to be a cancelled google
i have questions about a disease all
right don't refer to it this way
and it's like no there's like it's like
a scale yeah it's like the
yeah yeah as you type in the word yeah
you know it's like it's like right now
probably shouldn't it's like on the
verge of red but it's like
[Laughter]
are you typing a word and it's like are
you sure you want to search that i'm
feeling lucky
okay don't assume all doris this is
health.com
are we really this dumb that we're
referring to health.com
to all right also these websites are
never you can never trust
these websites yeah five slurs that are
okay
exactly um i don't think so man
five ableist terms that you can say
again
you may have heard the word
and this was bad back in the day but you
can say it again
we oh dude we should build a counter
culture
health site where we just promote morons
to like say insensitive stuff
do you oh man wait wait did you do that
college
show with me or no it might have been
one that i did alone it was with
it was this uh
[Applause]
i don't yeah i don't think it's the host
of this one
she goes she's asking me questions and
then she's like okay
uh uh we have another like would you
rather hear
and it was like would you rather be like
something or be
uh uh m yeah ableist slur that people
say for little people she said that and
i was like i don't think you can say
that and she was like
you can't oh i don't think so and
there's like a thousand people watching
the zoom and they're all the chats like
lighting up like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] i was like just move on to the next
question
instantly oh man it was oh man
it was pretty bad what's her name we
need to send her to the cancel group
i'm not i'm not what's her full name and
it's senator the canceled blue log right
now i know i fell back and she didn't
even know she was like what
yeah well yeah no well she can not about
that she's gonna apologize when she has
all her teeth missing
yeah then she'll show us that she's
sorry jesus
that's what we're doing in 2022 we're
violence
you say something insensitive or
ignorant we're knocking your teeth out
someone shows up to your door and just
puts a a louisville slugger through your
teeth jesus christ we're getting spicy
this is sorry
too much do we need to cut this now
all right um so yeah
so this is uh you know what it is i put
on i put on all this
this gold and it's just it's gotta be
acting
yeah yeah i was about to say the energy
radiating between these two accessories
is just
making me crazy you got big drug dealer
energy right now yeah do i
yeah yeah a couple dudes got excited
when they when this episode started like
oh let me get eight oh [ __ ]
it's just noel was like [ __ ]
coke dealer
[Laughter]
every white girl watching this fight
i'll get a bump whoa where did that come
from
whoa
can we just have like a k sorry
uh yeah all right yeah so they're gonna
fight
what's the what's the point of the fight
though is it just to fight
to make money oh so is it like a
pay-per-view or
but yeah it is and is it [ __ ] up to
buy the fight
yeah i wasn't going to i wasn't gonna i
wasn't gonna buy it i would never buy
that
messed up right i mean is it you're
supporting him
yo my boy on the right and the first
picture
that stance is mean yeah you see how you
see how like
he is no i mean he's perfectly
balanced in the center just like the way
he's showing him like oh you're you're
saying technically it's yeah
look how technical it is you see how
he's behind his hands like look at that
my boy on the left for a baby
that baby would [ __ ] up other babies man
if we're talking about
any anyone else his size like trying to
fight him they get their ass
beat i don't know about my boy on the
left because look at look how lazy that
is
yeah but i like the guy on the left his
his facial expression that
he is like yeah he's just kind of like
like
grimace he's doing a grimace he's like
that cat oh yeah yeah
he's kind of doing that same sort of
pout you know
i feel like he doesn't really give a
[ __ ] he's like i'm just here for the
cash
it's ben askren yeah exactly he's about
to get laid out
yeah we can do this man or maybe he's
just like why are you posturing so heavy
we're
we're toddler-sized it's not going to
hurt yeah exactly yeah
you couldn't really we couldn't do [ __ ]
to each other let's be honest here
that's kind of the best
if you can imagine that dude if you
could what if there was like some magic
weight
where it could really not produce any
harm
and it's like oh yeah me and this guy
can do a 20 round boxing match
everyone's like no [ __ ] way yeah
it doesn't hurt yeah go forever yeah
super smash brothers
yeah yeah that's true it's probably you
know
that weight is probably like this weight
i guess this is supposed to be one of
the most anticipated fights of the year
like in terms of
pay-per-view buys like they're
anticipating it to be like huge
what yeah all right
and uh why we should maybe we should
livestream ourselves watching it no that
would be bad
i'm not gonna watch it yeah that'd be
yeah you can't support that you can't
support it
i want to see like an unethical uh fight
card
where it features like dog fights and
chicken fire
somewhere like i just if if people are
if people are really gonna milk this
whole like pay-per-view combat sports
thing i wanna see someone shameless like
some greasy fight promoter
you know like burnt from the thai sun
just like ah yeah i hang out at all the
kickboxing gyms i'll tell you what real
entertainment is
chickens man we're doing [ __ ] fights
we're doing dog fights
we're gonna have kids fight on this card
man it's gonna be epic all right it's
gonna be carnage like you've never seen
before and everyone
has to have that moral dilemma where
you're like oh
how much does that take i was i would
never
pay any more than 50.
but 40. i want to see dude two dudes
cockfight actual cockfight i think you
can find that
like yeah i'm talking for pay-per-view
though like fight to the death oh
with their dicks with their dicks
[ __ ] fights that's oh man that's a
savage way to go
smothered to death with balls
not even [ __ ] just man
just grown man put his nuts in your
you